hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on 400 again and today
we have lots of information to talk
about today
such as the price of the new hero how
we're gonna be able to buy this new
character as we don't have a year past
this time around so
that was a lot of complaints and
questions about that as well as when it
comes out for players the move set the
armor for the character and the new
event weapons no
stuff on the event and if there's gonna
be any game modes or anything
or anything on the event battle pass
itself just strictly on the new event
weapons
but before we get into the info for
today i want to talk about today's
sponsor project orochi
i've partnered with them in the past and
they're going to be promoting their
season 4 clothing drop and as usual
there's tons of little hints to games
within the apparel
like the four honor drop with characters
such as yarman gunder nobushi gladiator
shugoki and kensei all appearing in the
designs as subtle references like the
snakes or an oni mask
some of these designs i showed as well
are also available in different colors
and clothing options like hoodies
for sakiro fans we have the father owl
shinobi sword saint and divine dragon
design
which of course are all references to
the game in some way and there's even
the ghost of tsushima design referencing
the new samurai game coming soon
ghost of tsushima there's obviously a
lot more designs than what i showed here
in the video
so definitely go check the website if
you want to see all of them
other than that they offer worldwide
shipping and it's free if you're within
the us
and if you want to see more of their
releases before anyone else be sure to
follow their instagram project orochi so
you can be some of the first people to
see some of the new designs that they
come up with as always thank you to
project orochi for sponsoring the
content and let's continue on with
today's news for today
so yeah hopefully you enjoyed that
promotion from project orochi of course
check the link down in the description
but for the information on the hero the
hero will be available on august 6th and
she will be costing eight dollars usd
and you can get the hero for two weeks
exclusivity
after the two weeks is up she will be
then 15 000 steel
for everybody there is no need to
purchase some event pass or
is some year pass as there isn't one
this time around so if you purchase her
for eight dollars then you will be
getting her for those two weeks but if
you do not purchase her
you have to wait until those two weeks
is up the eight dollars goes away and
then she has 15 000 steel
so that's how you're going to be getting
her and that 15k steal i believe should
be exactly two weeks after on august
20th
they also showed some of the lore for
the character which by the story is
actually warmonger as a group is like i
said just one whole group they're
related to the warriors of horcos which
we have been seeing in the battle pass a
lot
and they are actually a part of that
group that attacked the wulin at the end
of year three in the qiyang pass which
was the pvp event mode with the
commander
that was actually the warriors of horcos
they gained weaponry from the ruling
from that fight which was of course the
draconite which causes all the
corruption
and then continued their slaughter i
know it was the blackstone legion during
that event
but the horcos is actually a little bit
of a group of apollyon's army and this
these new people as well which we'll
kind of get into lots of people
commented on why warmonger was a only
english-speaking character this is
actually due to the fact that they want
people to join their cause so they try
to speak the most common language
possible which is english that's
actually the reason why
she of course also wields the flomberg
sword and she is actually gender locked
to female so there will be no males in
the game
even though there is probably males
within the story as the warmonger is not
one specific person it is actually a
group of people
the main main warmonger and the leader
of the horcose
is actually the character we play astera
and remember of course that the
dragonite was found during the wulin
during the qiying pass battle which is
why they use that as poison
and that they will be using that power
to corrupt the world that is a little
bit of the story of the character and
where these horcos kind of fit in
next up we have the moveset and she has
a few basic combos she has light light
heavy
heavy heavy heavy light heavy i may have
also missed one they were kind of
showing multiple combos
back and forth but i think you can get
the gist from the video
you can also notice that some of the
heavies also have armor and the lights
are enhanced this is theirs for a lot of
different reasons but we'll get into
those a little bit later
and of course as well she also has the
zone attack this can of course combo
with lights and other heavies
after lights and i also think heavies as
well and even side and front dodges you
can do this bash as we'll call it and
this is why her
her lights are enhanced to actually make
this move viable
you can throw a light attack and then
immediately go into this bash
she also has this other unblockable move
called the bearer of prey which is very
similar actually to apollyon's we'll
call it ultimate move from the campaign
or even if you played in test your metal
you could do a move very similar to this
after a dodge and then inputting an
attack and then that's the unblockable
and you can also chain off this move if
you happen to land it
she also has a front dodge heavy and
it's undodgeable and of course you can
faint this as well if you so choose to
so you can catch a bunch of different
people using this move
and after a parry you can impale the
opponent very similar to lawbringer
but it's more damage if you happen to
hit them into the wall this isn't
something like a lawbringer's case where
if you go into the wall you can throw a
heavy it just automatically does a type
of damage move as soon as they hit the
wall
and of course legend is available for
this move and
there's also a different version of this
move if you happen to parry an attack
and the opponent falls over due to them
being out of stamina
you can immediately stab the ground and
that will take dan they will also take
damage as well
so there's multiple different ways to
land this move now for her feats her
tier 1 is essentially noosh's tier 4.
anyone who steps in the circle when it's
placed on the opponent
takes damage along with that person who
is affected by the affliction
if no one is in the circle no one takes
damage you can see as the raider's
health doesn't move when he moves away
from the kensei
as while he does have the corruption
around him none of his allies are
actually in the circle with him
this is more to separate ganks and
spread fights out you can apply this
buff to your blade and you need to get a
confirmed hit for it to proc and you
have about 15 seconds or so
for it to land for her tier 2 she
actually gains health when she fights a
corrupted enemy the more damage they
take the more you heal
even if the opponent is alone since they
are still considered corrupted
you heal off of it they just have to be
corrupted that is the only way for this
to work
so obviously tier 2 works but now we
also have tier 3 which means corrupted
targets take more damage and you can
kind of see where these correlate as if
tier 2
heals you from the damage you deal and
tier 3 makes you do more damage
then you're essentially going to be
healing more damage and that's exactly
what this does for tier 3
corrupted targets take more damage so
the more damage you deal the more you
heal and of course thanks to tier three
you're doing even more damage
and tier two and tier three goes really
well together i absolutely love these
two as a combo
for tier four it's corruption blast this
is an aoe that hits people in a circle
around her since the corruption overlaps
each other they're actually all killing
each other at the exact same time having
uh person a in one circle and person b
in the same circle everybody's taking
damage but then also person b
has a circle so they're taking damage
from him so it's actually double damage
but then person c comes in and other
taking triple damage
you can see where this is going so the
biggest thing with her is to get
away from her if you're in a gank that's
what she wants
ganks work in her favor so isolate her
you want to get her into a one-on-one so
that her corruption does as little as
possible as to not kill the entire team
trying to kill one person and also this
is also going to be very deadly for
warmongers who are breaking and she is
the very last one alive as she can wipe
out an entire team very
quickly even by herself assuming she has
the tier 4 feat
and also if you're a person that's
afflicted by this corruption
watch the circle stay away from your
team because not only are you killing
them
you're killing yourself along with them
next up is her customization and she
actually has this unique idea called
alternate armor she has this set of
regular armor but then
a set of alternate armor which is the
same as the original just slight changes
which makes the armor look really really
nice for those people that want to get
rid of a few details
i want to explain this a bit more so
let's just say for the sake of an
example that every single character that
releases that's new gets 20 new sets of
armor right just as an example
that doesn't mean that warmonger gets 20
regular armor and then 20 alternate
armor
that means that she has 10 regular armor
and 10 alternate armor right that
doesn't mean she just gets double the
armor than everybody else got
she just has a half of half of the armor
that she comes with is the regular the
other half is the alternate version i
want to make that very clear
and this isn't some new mechanic for the
game this is just something unique to
her right now
does that mean that we're going to get
this stuff in the future maybe but this
is
really for those people that you know
love a specific type of armor but
absolutely hate the cape on it or
something like that
for example you'll be seeing stuff like
antlers and then ones without antlers
and i'm actually a huge fan of the
antler set
one of them even looks like wardens
ornament and a helm without the needed
for all that steel that warden players
would have to do so kind of interesting
but like i stated it's not a new
mechanic that all the other characters
in the game are going to be getting it's
just something specific to her at the
moment and it's just like normal armor
the game will state of course whether it
is alternate armor and you can of course
mix these pieces so if you want to have
from the regular estera armor you want
to have the regular head
and the regular arms but the alternate
like body chest version
you can totally do that and as you're
going to be seeing some of them actually
have a lot more detail than others even
when comparing the alternate versions of
the exact same armor some even have way
more detail
than the others do and it's really cool
looking i'm unsure if it's at this part
in the video but i guess we'll spoil it
anyway as it's going to be shown in the
video
yes as the new character warmonger you
can have the original apollyon armor
from the campaign
you can literally wield her armor from
the game
and this comes of course with an
alternate version which has changes to
the cape and plume
excited a lot of people from the very
beginning of the game have been stating
that they want characters to match up
with specific pieces of armor
people have wanted goodman dars armor
for warlord apollyon for warden
tozens for orochi all that type of stuff
and while this isn't exactly what we
wanted
it's pretty similar and i'm totally cool
with it as we actually get to use one of
the boss's armor pieces
in the game even though it's not for
warden as a lot of people of course
wanted or thought
it's for a whole new character and i
think that's totally fine
and like i said none of these really
look the same besides the default and
apollyon armor of course as they are
very similar and the default armor is
actually based off of apollyon's armor
thanks to the lore and stuff like that
and it doesn't really seem like
everybody looks the same and it's a nice
way to stand out a lot of characters
kind of fall into this trap mostly
characters that aren't knights i've
noticed mostly the samurai
i've seen on a few instances for some of
the characters where
a high level version of the character
looks the exact same as the low-level
version and it's really hard to
determine
you know what the person's rep is just
by looking at them now of course some
people use the low tier armor
but some characters look the same at rep
30 as they do at rep
2 and for this character that is not the
case
on top of there also being the apollyon
armor there's also slight changes to the
apollyon armor like a more shinier
version
if people want those so if you're a
super big fan of apollyon which honestly
this character is
practically based off of polygon to
begin with so you kind of gotta be
there's a bunch of different options for
you to use and if you even if you don't
like her armor there's loads of other
options without her armor and it's just
you know it's its own unique design
that you can use as well there's
probably a good chance that
not all the armor has been shown if it
has sick but if not then i'll be showing
the rest of it without my commentary and
then we'll move on to the weapons
now we get into the weapons of warmonger
and the weapon she would is actually the
flomberg
and multiple different versions of its
variation
you can customize the blade the hilt and
the handle like a typical sword
customization in the game so warden
players should not feel too
out of whack with this type of weapon
just as before we have extremely unique
weapons so to let people stand
out some of them are just very
straightforward and typical swords but
some are very much more exaggerated in
the handle guard or blade
with some having two guards some having
a large different hilt
and of course some of them even having
curvy blades gold blades and stuff like
that
for story purposes the reason that they
have all these unique and specific
weapons is
to basically attract new potential
recruits to join the horcos showing that
they have accumulated
lots of wealth and that you should join
their group there are a few gold weapons
but i know a lot of people don't really
like the gold weapons for characters of
course so
there is other different versions of the
non-gold looking weapons there's some
that are more in silver
some that are more in black and even one
that has a rose on it that is more
dabbled in red colors so that's enough
for everybody and anybody's taste
now the weapons are done we're on to the
final part of the video which is the new
event weapons now of course like i
stated in the beginning of the video
we'll not be going over the event battle
pass or anything that's a part of the
event
like if there's a new game mode or
anything like that as that was not
covered in today's video that may have
to be covered in a future stream
this was only about the new event
weapons and only those weapons
and these will be a part of the event
not a part of the past as there is
different content
for that pass but there is only weapons
for the event unlocked like just any
normal event ever
just play the character and eventually
you'll get the weapon parts for that
character that's how you're going to
unlock these weapons just very normal
you could tell there is a clear theme
for these weapons as there is a more
rustic corrupted looking weapon look
going on and this yellow stone
stuff is actually the draconite which is
on the weapons itself to of course
spread that corruption and rustic vibe
so anybody that wants to build a
character around this would
automatically look amazing
these look very intimidating and
actually very unsettling and i think
that's the point that they're
going for stuff that's corrupted and
rustic isn't supposed to look cute and
really cool looking of course the cool
stuff is fine but it's really supposed
to give players a very unsettling feel
especially the people that are even
wielding it and of course any character
with large amounts of space on the
weapon like warlord and hitoki
are gonna have a field day with these
weapons as they have so much room to
work with
and they always have amazing looking
weapons on top of the rustic and
corrupted materials some have skulls on
them as well like shugokis
do some solid work with those and the
weapon also before black priors is being
shown
is the warmonger weapon i'll make sure
to put during the video as this plays an
arrow to show you that that is the new
warmonger weapon
of course i just didn't want anybody to
be confused that that was maybe
highlander or confused why there's a
whole new weapon in there
as that is the new character warmongers
she has a really cool looking weapon and
honestly one of my favorites that has
come out throughout this event weapon
little section here that we have for the
video
and now that the weapons are over we're
actually on to the very very final thing
but i didn't exactly mention as it was
super tiny it's the new content of the
week which is the horcose grimoire emote
which is pretty much you busting out a
grimoire and you reading it in the game
it's infinitely playing like shaman's
collapse you can stay that way forever
or if it's not infinitely playing it's
long as [ __ ] as that looks like 30 to 40
seconds so i'm just convinced that it's
just gonna keep
looping and this of course is available
for all players it might be 7000 steel
maybe 5k
i'm just gonna go with seven just to put
it as a baseline for the steel count
but yeah that's the new stuff for this
dev stream that we've been talking about
like i said we talked about the armor we
talked about the weapons
talked about the move set talked about
the new event weapons the new content of
the week
a lot of new details that players were
asking for of course on how do we get
this character because there's no year
past this is a very weird time
it's most likely going to be the exact
same for the character that comes in
season four it's gonna be like eight or
nine dollars
pay for the character get it for two
weeks before everybody else and people
that don't want to spend money on the
game could spend 15 000 steal
after two weeks then you get to play the
character and everyone gets the player
and yeah that's gonna be the video guys
let me know what you guys think about
this stuff in the comments down below
like to be if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new of course check out project
orochi down in the description they make
some amazing looking merchandise so of
course check them out
and you can obviously use the discount
code down in the description and with
that take care have a ghost today peace
out i'll see you for another video in
the future goodbye
[Music]
you